esto es algo que solía confundirme
tenemos dos cargas que las vamos a
llamar q1 y q2 y si tenemos estas cargas
juntas y la soltamos se van a separar ya
que se repelen mutuamente las cargas
iguales se repelen así que q 2 va a ser
empujada hacia la derecha y q 1 va a ser
empujada hacia la izquierda por lo que
ambas van a comenzar a ganar energía
cinética van a aumentar su velocidad
pero si estas cargas comienzan a ganar
energía cinética de donde vino esa
energía es decir si creemos en la
conservación de la energía esta energía
tuvo que venir de algún lugar así que de
dónde viene esta energía cinética pues
de la energía potencial eléctrica
decimos que la energía potencial
eléctrica se está transformando en
energía cinética así que originalmente
en este sistema tenemos energía
potencial eléctrica y después tendremos
menos energía potencial eléctrica pero
más energía cinética así que conforme la
energía potencial eléctrica disminuye la
a cinética aumenta pero la energía total
en este sistema de dos cargas permanece
igual y es de aquí de donde viene la
energía cinética viene de la energía
potencial eléctrica y la letra que los
físicos normalmente usan para
representar la energía potencial es una
1 porque eligen una u para representar
la energía potencial no tengo idea de
que también hubiera tenido sentido ya
que son las iniciales de energía
potencial pero es más común encontrarla
así con una u a veces le ponen una como
subíndice para indicar que es energía
potencial eléctrica y no por ejemplo
energía potencial gravitacional esto
está bien tenemos que la energía
potencial eléctrica se transforma en
energía cinética y conocemos la fórmula
de la energía cinética de estas cargas
encontramos la energía cinética de estas
cargas al tener un medio de la masa de
una de las cargas multiplicada por la
rapidez de una de estas cargas al
cuadrado y cuál es la fórmula para
la energía potencial eléctrica entre
estas dos cargas pues si tenemos dos o
más cargas que se encuentran juntas
existe alguna fórmula para encontrar la
cantidad de energía potencial eléctrica
en este sistema la buena noticia es que
si la hay y es una fórmula bastante
buena para encontrar esto la mala
noticia es que para deducir esta fórmula
necesitamos cálculo y no vamos a usar la
deducción usando cálculo en este vídeo
ya tenemos un vídeo que habla de esto
pero en este vídeo vamos a ver el
resultado
veremos cómo usarlo y haremos un
recorrido por así decirlo de esta
fórmula y la fórmula luce así para
encontrar la energía potencial eléctrica
entre dos cargas tomamos con la
constante eléctrica la multiplicamos por
una de las cargas multiplicamos por la
otra carga y esto lo dividimos entre la
distancia que separa a los centros de
ambas cargas que llamamos r
esto lo medimos del centro de una carga
hasta el centro de la otra carga la
distancia entre ellas esto es r y no la
elevamos al cuadrado en muchas de estas
fórmulas por ejemplo en la ley de colom
la r siempre se eleva al cuadrado para
los campos eléctricos también la r se
eleva al cuadrado pero para la energía
potencial eléctrica está r no se eleva
al cuadrado básicamente en la deducción
de esta fórmula realizamos una integral
que hace que esta r al cuadrado se
vuelva una erre solita así que no
intenten elevarla al cuadrado en esta
ocasión la dejamos como r y esto es esta
es la fórmula para encontrar la energía
potencial eléctrica en un sistema de
cargas y aquí hay algo que solía
confundirme yo solía preguntarme si ésta
era la energía potencial eléctrica de
esta carga o de esta otra carga la mejor
forma de pensar en esto es decir que
esta fórmula nos da la energía potencial
eléctrica del sistema de cargas
al menos dos cargas para poder tener
energía potencial eléctrica si sólo
tuviéramos una carga no tendríamos
energía potencial eléctrica así que
piensen en esta energía potencial
eléctrica como la energía potencial del
sistema de cargas y ya que esta es
energía potencial eléctrica toda la
energía tiene unidades de jules al menos
si usamos unidades del sistema
internacional tendremos unidades de
jules otra cosa que es importante es que
esta energía potencial eléctrica es una
escala es decir no es un vector esta
energía no tiene una dirección es sólo
una cantidad con una unidad que nos dice
cuánta energía potencial hay en este
sistema y estas son buenas noticias ya
que cuando tenemos vectores tenemos que
descomponer los en sus elementos
fundamentales y potencialmente
tendríamos problemas de componentes de
vectores tendríamos que averiguar cuánto
de este vector apunta hacia la derecha y
cuánto de este vector apunta hacia
arriba esta energía no tiene dirección
por lo que no tendremos componentes de
vectores así que cómo podemos usar esta
fórmula para resolver
problemas veamos un problema de ejemplo
para darnos una idea de cómo usar esta
fórmula digamos que este es nuestro
problema de ejemplo conocemos las cargas
comenzamos en reposo y estas cargas
están separadas una distancia de tres
centímetros y después de que las
soltamos estando en reposo dejamos que
se separen una distancia de 12
centímetros y necesitamos conocer una
cosa más necesitamos conocer la masa de
cada carga y digamos que cada carga
tiene una masa de un kilogramo para que
podamos hacer nuestros cálculos sin
problemas y la pregunta que queremos
resolver es qué tan rápido se van a
estar moviendo estas cargas una vez que
se hayan separado 12 centímetros
la carga azul q no se va a estar
moviendo hacia la izquierda y la carga
morada q2 se va a estar moviendo hacia
la derecha qué tan rápido se van a estar
moviendo para responder a esto vamos a
usar la conservación de la energía para
un sistema de energía que incluye a
ambas cargas y digamos que si incluimos
a todo
esto en nuestro sistema entonces la
energía total inicial de mi sistema va a
ser igual a la energía total final del
sistema qué tipo de energía tiene
inicialmente nuestro sistema pues el
sistema comienza en reposo así que no
tenemos energía cinética por lo que
inicialmente sólo tendremos energía
potencial eléctrica a esto le llamamos
inicial y esto va a tener que ser igual
a la energía final una vez que las
cargas se hayan separado 12 centímetros
y mientras más separadas estén van a
tener menos energía potencial eléctrica
pero seguirán teniendo algo de energía
potencial eléctrica a esta le llamamos
un final y ahora las cargas se van a
estar moviendo y si las cargas se mueven
van a tener energía cinética así que a
esto le sumamos la energía cinética del
sistema usamos nuestra fórmula para la
energía potencial eléctrica y nos queda
que la energía potencial eléctrica
inicial es 9 por 10 a la nueve ya que
ésta es mi constante eléctrica k
multiplicada por la carga de q
es de 4 micro cool oms y micro es 10 a
la menos 6 así que tenemos que poner
esto como cullom son regulares lo
multiplicamos por q 2 que es de 2 micro
coloms o 2 por 10 a la menos 6 kilos
dividido entre la distancia de las
cargas y como esta es la energía
potencial inicial pues la distancia
inicial es de 3 centímetros y aunque 3
centímetros es la distancia de centro al
centro entre estas cargas no puedo poner
aquí directamente el 3 ya que estos son
centímetros y si quiero que mis unidades
sean en jules y obtenga mis velocidades
en metros por segundo tengo que
convertir esto a metros y 3 centímetros
son 0.03 metros lo dividimos entre 100
ya que hay 100 centímetros en un metro y
esto no lo elevó al cuadrado esta ere
que divide no está elevada al cuadrado y
todo esto va a ser igual a otro término
que luce muy similar de hecho vamos a
copiar y pegar esto aquí la única
diferencia es que
ahora es la energía potencial eléctrica
final el valor de k no cambia se
mantiene también igual el valor de las
cargas y lo único que cambia es la
distancia centro al centro entre estas
dos cargas así que en lugar de estar
separadas tres centímetros estarán
separadas 12 centímetros así que aquí
ponemos 0.1 2 metros ya que 12
centímetros son punto 12 metros y a esto
le tenemos que agregar la energía
cinética y a esto le vamos a llamar acá
por ahora la energía cinética total
final del sistema después que alcanzaron
una distancia de 12 centímetros si
hacemos todos estos cálculos del lado
izquierdo nos quedan 2.4 jules de
energía potencial eléctrica inicial y
esto va a ser igual a nuestro cálculo de
todo esto de acá
multiplicó las cargas las dividido entre
punto 12 y lo multiplicó por 9 por 10 a
la 9 y nos queda 0.6 jules
de energía potencial eléctrica después
de que se separaron 12 centímetros de
distancia más la energía cinética final
del sistema así que podemos reemplazar
esta acá por la fórmula de la energía
cinética en nuestro sistema que es de un
medio por m por b al cuadrado pero aquí
hay un problema
estas dos cargas se están moviendo por
lo que si queremos hacer esto
correctamente debemos tomar en cuenta
que ambas cargas van a tener energía
cinética no solo una de ellas si solo
escribo un medio por un kilogramo por b
al cuadrado tendré la respuesta
equivocada ya que habré ignorado el
hecho de que la otra carga también tiene
energía cinética por lo que podemos
hacer una de dos cosas ya que estas
masas son iguales van a tener la misma
rapidez por lo que podríamos escribir
aquí esta masa como de dos kilogramos
multiplicada por la rapidez común al
cuadrado o podemos escribir dos términos
uno para cada carga y esto es más fácil
de hacer porque nos evita confusiones
a hacer lo resolvemos esto 2.4 2.6 es
igual a 1.8 jules y esto va a ser igual
a un medio por masa que es un kilogramo
por b al cuadrado que es la rapidez de
esta segunda carga al cuadrado más un
medio por un kilogramo por la rapidez de
la primera partícula al cuadrado y aquí
podemos argumentar que ya que ambas
partículas tienen la misma masa se van a
mover con la misma rapidez y un medio
por b al cuadrado más un medio por d al
cuadrado nos dará b al cuadrado ya que
un medio debe al cuadrado más otro medio
debe al cuadrado nos dará de cuadrado
entero y si son listos me pueden decir a
ver un momento esta carga aún teniendo
la misma masa tiene más carga que esta
carga de aquí y no será que esta carga
se mueve más rápido ya que tiene más
carga pues no no es así la fuerza que
estas cargas van a ejercer entre sí
siempre es la misma aún cuando tengan
cargas diferentes
no le veamos mucho sentido pero es
cierto la tercera ley de newton nos dice
que esto se tiene que cumplir
así que si ejercen la misma fuerza entre
ellas en la misma distancia entonces
realizarán la misma cantidad de trabajo
entre sí y si tienen la misma masa
quiere decir que van a terminar con la
misma rapidez ambas así que tenemos la
misma rapidez y esta rapidez es una
variable común entre estos términos por
lo que si quiero encontrarme tengo que
sacar la raíz cuadrada en ambos lados y
me queda que la rapidez de ambas cargas
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 1.8 y
técnicamente tengo que dividir estos
jules entre un kilogramo ya que aunque
esto fue un 1 para obtener las unidades
correctas
debo tener jules por kilogramo y si hago
esta raíz cuadrada me va a quedar 1.3
metros por segundo esta es la rapidez a
la que se estarán moviendo estas dos
cargas cuando tengan una distancia de
separación de 12 centímetros
conceptualmente la energía potencial
eléctrica se transforma en energía
cinética por lo que la energía potencial
eléctrica final
es menor a la energía potencial
eléctrica inicial y toda esta energía se
fue a la energía cinética de cada una de
las cargas ya resolvimos este problema
pero ahora qué pasaría si en lugar de
comenzar con estas cargas en reposo
separadas por tres centímetros
comenzarán en reposo separadas 12
centímetros pero ahora haríamos esta q2
negativa así que en lugar de tener dos
micro clones positivos ahora tendríamos
menos dos micro culos y ahora que esta
carga es negativa se va a sentir atraída
a la carga positiva y de la misma forma
la carga positiva se va a sentir atraída
hacia la carga negativa así que digamos
que las liberamos comenzando en reposo y
estaban separadas 12 centímetros y
dejamos que se acerquen mutuamente hasta
que estén separadas 3 centímetros y nos
hacemos la misma pregunta qué rapidez
van a tener estas partículas cuando
lleguen a estar separadas solamente por
3 centímetros así que qué va a cambiar
en nuestros cálculos aquí ya que siguen
comenzando en reposo comenzó
con cero energía cinética así que esto
no cambia pero en esta ocasión no
comenzaron separadas tres centímetros
sino comenzaron separadas 12 centímetros
así que en lugar de comenzar con 3 y
terminar con 12 ahora comienzan con 12 y
terminan con 3 que más cambia aquí la
única otra cosa que cambia es el signo
de q2 y quizá piensen quizás no es buena
idea poner los signos de las cargas aquí
ya que eso me puede confundir pero esto
sólo era para el campo eléctrico y para
la fuerza eléctrica como estos no son
vectores podemos incluir los signos de
las cargas sin ningún problema de hecho
es algo que debemos hacer incluimos los
negativos y los positivos y esta fórmula
nos va a dar una energía potencial
eléctrica positiva o negativa según sea
el caso
no nos gusta incluir los signos en las
fórmulas del campo eléctrico y la fuerza
eléctrica ya que esos son vectores y si
son vectores debemos decidir en cual
dirección apuntan y el signo negativo
nos puede llevar a un error
pero en este caso no nos va a afectar el
signo solo nos dirá si tenemos energía
potencial eléctrica positiva o energía
potencial eléctrica negativa aquí no
tenemos que estar descomponiendo
vectores ni nada por el estilo ya que
todos estos son escalares así que en
pocas palabras incluimos el signo de
cada carga y esta fórmula nos dará el
resultado correcto ya que es un escalar
y no tenemos que preocuparnos por estar
descomponiendo vectores es decir en
lugar de tener un 2 aquí voy a poner un
menos 2 y en lugar de tener un 2
positivo en este otro lado tendré un
menos 2
así que si resolvemos el lado izquierdo
de la ecuación no se sorprenderán de que
nos dé menos puntos 6 jules de energía
potencial inicial y esto nos podría
preocupar quizás me digan a ver un
momento cómo es que comenzamos con
energía potencial negativa y quizás me
digan es que esto no tiene sentido cómo
podemos obtener energía cinética de un
sistema que comience con energía
potencial menor que cero es bastante
extraño cómo es que puedo comenzar con
menos que cero o igual a cero energía
potencial y aún así obtener energía
cinética de esto pues es porque este
término el término de la energía
potencial eléctrica final va a ser más
negativo aún si cálculo esto me va a
quedar menos 2.4 jules y esto le
agregamos la energía cinética final del
sistema en otras palabras nuestro
sistema sigue ganando energía cinética
porque sigue perdiendo energía potencial
y sólo porque tengamos energía potencial
negativa no quiere decir que no podamos
tener menos energía potencial al menos
comparada con la que iniciamos es como
las finanzas si ustedes comienzan con
una deuda
no significa que no puedan gastar dinero
pueden tener una tarjeta de crédito y
aumentar su deuda pueden tener cosas aun
cuando no tengan dinero obtengan dinero
negativo una deuda solo significa que se
van a endeudar más y más lo cual no es
una buena decisión financiera pero es lo
que está haciendo esta energía potencial
se está endeudando cada vez más para
poder financiar un aumento en la energía
cinética no es la mejor decisión
financiera pero esto es física no hay
problema
así que resolvemos esto para la energía
cinética del sistema sumamos 2.4 jules
en ambos lados de la igualdad y nos
queda 1.8 jules positivos del lado
izquierdo esto es igual aquí tenemos dos
términos ya que ambas partículas se van
a estar moviendo por lo que aquí tenemos
un medio de un kilogramo por la rapidez
de una de las cargas al cuadrado más un
medio por un kilogramo por la rapidez de
la otra de las cargas al cuadrado que
nuevamente nos da b al cuadrado y si
calculamos b
obtener el mismo valor que la vez
anterior de 1.3 metros por segundo en
resumen la fórmula para la energía
potencial eléctrica entre dos cargas es
k por q no por q 2 / ere y ya que la
energía es escalar podemos incluir los
signos de las cargas involucradas lo que
nos dirá si la energía potencial
eléctrica es positiva o es negativa y ya
que esto es energía podemos usarla en la
fórmula de la conservación de la energía
y es posible que los sistemas tengan
energía potencial eléctrica negativa y
estos sistemas aún así pueden convertir
energía potencial eléctrica en energía
cinética solamente se tienen que
asegurar que su energía potencial
eléctrica se vuelva aún más negativa